your book is phenomenal i enjoyed it
immensely i've been a fan of snl
uh since i can remember so let's start
with a title a very punchable face
uh you know i think most people like
find that funny and there's like a theme
of self-deprecation throughout the book
um so what were the what was the process
behind you're deciding on a title
because i know the title of your first
book is actually kind of a big decision
it is it's like with music you put on an
album
the first one can just be your name you
know it's easy no you know
that's just like the industry standard
you got an eponymous album but that
you know with books you gotta actually
think about it you know um
i wanna i also before i start wanted to
thank you
um i i was very honored that you that
you agreed to do this and talk to me
and i'm a big fan of yours and i think
what you brought to the campaign was
such an elevated and
fresh set of ideas and
you were just really fun to watch and
also
you you you like it was the only new
ideas that were out there and i really
uh i i don't know i gained like a whole
new
uh like idea of what a candidate could
be from watching you
and i hope that your ideas continue and
that you continue
and and make them a reality because it
was really inspiring to see so thank you
and and thank you for doing this because
it means a lot um
i uh i i wrote about
a lot of so there's a lot of
self-deprecating and humiliating
things in my book i i really wanted it
always my book to be entertaining
um i didn't want it to be trying to be
overly
educational or pedantic in any way or i
didn't want it to be
just taking weird victory laps about
anything or
or just like name dropping stuff i
wanted it to be
stories that i thought were were you
know that were funny and that people
would
would like reading and and i i ran
everything through that filter
and it turns out a lot of those stories
ended up being ones
where i was injured or
humiliated or emotionally abused or
um you know just by my own
dumb decisions got injured or put in a
terrible position
and i i thought you know that would be
entertaining and it seems like people
do enjoy when i when when uh you know
injurious things happen to me
i i confess that after reading your book
like you did start to resemble
one of those action movie heroes in my
mind where like you take your shirt off
and then there's like
this scarf of that this is from like the
google mishap this is from the bike
this is from the surfing so you started
to resemble
that kind of figure in my mind
uh wow you're also as as we all know
you're engaged to
uh and like a superhero that you know
everyone's
growing up with so there's that too
maybe that's another reason why you
seemed like an action hero
i was gonna say you're a real superhero
but also that's not she's
it is a movie i guess so i confess to
being
and this is one thing i liked about your
book too is that like you know your book
was very very personal um but like you
said it wasn't like a name dropping type
book it was like personal about your
childhood personal uh about
your formative experiences which were
very funny like consistently
um i you know i feel like i understand
staten island better thanks to
to your book and and also i i happen to
have seen um king of staten island uh
you know relatively recently and so like
between that
and your book like i feel like
i understand the fifth borough uh
hopefully it's not an insult he called
the fit bro
that's one of the nicest things anyone's
ever said about that island
staten island we're part of new york
that's true it's real
it's clear
and so you went from staten island you
went to high school in the city which
also had many many funny
anecdotes certainly the most affecting
very very quintessentially new york
story i thought was the story of your
mom and her
bravery uh during 9 11 uh and
i was in new york um on that day
like i remember when the towers fell it
was a beautiful day in terms of the
weather like you know not a cloud in the
sky and then you
hear that a plane crashed in the world
trade center and i was
part of the crowd of thousands that just
started walking
away from downtown like i was near the
empire state building
i showed up to work and then this
happens and then everyone in the office
is like we should get the heck out of
here
and then we start walking north um but
your mom did the opposite your mom
actually headed towards
the towers which to me is probably the
most heroic thing i can imagine doing
having been on the island that day
like every human instinct is like go
away from
uh from what is happening and she
actually went went towards it
yeah i mean um it's
i i don't know how that that instinct
happens i think she
she you probably don't know until that
that moment happens how you're gonna
handle it
and i think it probably for her came
from
knowing that all her you know all the
the firefighters that she knew and
worked with
and and loved were all in there were
were closer or near the buildings and
and i think she genuinely wanted to
help them um and and help get them out
of that situation or help treat them
um you know i don't think she i don't
think she
ever imagined that the that the
buildings would both fall
you know i think that she didn't you
know she knew they had been hit
and she kind of gradually figured out
once the pentagon had been
hit that it was a that there was a
clearly a coordinated terrorist
act but i don't think she ever thought
structurally something like that would
happen i mean
it was so crazy to start seeing
happening because you don't
even when things get hit you know you
just don't expect that to happen so
maybe she uh you know i don't know that
she ever thought that that
i don't think she could imagine that
that would have happened yeah well
that chapter certainly humanized you and
your family uh
in an incredible way because frankly
people look at you
and think oh that's it now famous
celebrity engaged to a celebrity and
then when you when you read about
your mom rushing towards the towers uh
the fact that
her life was saved twice by firemen who
were like right there with her
that the people she was with um lost
their lives
uh that that day and then you imagine
you know you
and obviously like you know your people
associate this with uh with your cast
mate pete davidson as well
like you realize that like the human
condition
uh like it's uh it's
your family it's pete's family it's the
343 families that got
um uh that got devastated that day who
were families of firefighters and it
seems like
your family has so so much of like the
firefighter dna uh
like in your uh like your family's
history like i i felt like i got to know
you better
as a result of sharing in that
experience
it was you know it's such a it's the
community i knew the most and it was you
know like my
my grandfather was a fireman my
great-grandfather was a fireman all my
cousins and
uh my uncles everyone who lives on my
the block where my whole family lived
mostly on staten island
were all in the fire department so i
knew it forever as this
really fun community of all these like i
feel like firefighters are some of the
funniest people
and and really uh a loving group of
people
and then after that there was a whole
other you know obviously
elements to it and you and it was even
more of a community but in in a whole
different kind of way
um and i thought that one of the most uh
the things that my mom said that was
the craziest to me was you know when i
when i remember going
to visit uh the head you know fire
department headquarters where they have
they keep basically a wall of the names
of all the firefighters who who died in
the line of duty
and she said that in the first 100 years
of the department
they filled one wall and then that day
on september 11th they filled an entire
other wall
like that was that was what the sheer
numbers for the department were
and and and staten island obviously
including pete's dad was part of that
wall and a substantial part of that wall
on staten island so
um you know i i'm very proud of my mom
and that's why i wanted to write that
chapter and i really feel for her
of of going through that and losing
colleagues like that
yeah people i was i was surprised by so
much of your background because
you know i think a very high level view
is
um you went to harvard uh that's one
thing and you had like a really
fun uh set of stories about harvard uh
and so you don't think oh you know like
uh mother works for the fire department
uh you know grandfather
worked for was a fireman um you think
like oh he went to harvard so
you know maybe his parents were like
orthodontists
his parents were president and vice
president of harvard
or something yeah or something right
like the wiggle bot
yeah and then when you went to harvard
too like you framed it in such human
terms where like there's like this
harvard like mystique and then like you
unpacked it
in such a humble way
[Applause]
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to
yangspeaks and click on notifications so
we can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]